hallo zusammen das ist q&d zu mir der
Reportage Männer in der Krise wie
toxisch ist meine Männlichkeit als
erstes mal herzlichen Dank auch denen wo
kräftig mit diskutiert hey in der
Kommentar und auf Barcode unbedingt noch
IGA
RX Schritt es gibt kein ehrlichen
Diskurs man orientiert sich immer an den
extremen entweder gehört man zu einem
Hardcore Feministen
ja es gibt Arschlöcher deshalb jedoch
50% der Bevölkerung zu verurteilen ist
vielleicht nicht der richtige Ansatz hey
voll nur bloß das Parlament geht wo
katholing machen sie nicht automatisch
auch immer
behaupte aber ich finde man kriegt
trotzdem mal kritische Fragen
schreibt vor das Paar Jahr an in das
Rafael gesehen
Thema
hier warum Feminismus gut für Männer ist
vom Jens von tricht finde ich sehr
spannendes Buch zeigt das Feminismus
aber nicht unbedingt gleich Männer Hass
ist und vor allem aber wieso Männer
profitieren
was ist mit der toxischen Weiblichkeit
oder haben solche Charakterzüge nur
Männer hey die Frage ist sehr hoch
Wirklichkeit geht SRF Virus hat der
Begriff schon mal
belüftet immer spannender
Antwort ist ja es gibt toxische
Schwierigkeit aber Journalistin Marie
hätte ich seit dass ich toxische
Üblichkeit gegen
Frau richtet Angst aus die toxische
mannigkeit war aus Umfeld drumherum
von toxischen Männlichkeit oder der
Benachteiligung der Frau etc gesprochen
diese wird jedoch nie definiert und oder
belegt besonders hinsichtlich der
Benachteiligung der Frau in Erstlinge
müsste man sich die Frage stellen ob
2023 in der Schweiz tatsächlich noch ein
Netto Benachteiligung der Frau vorliegt
dazu geht es tatsächlich durchaus Zahlen
Bundesamt für Statistik verdienen Frauen
Schweiz immer noch 2500 Franken weniger
pro Monat
52% verdammt
Objektive Faktoren wie berufliche Stelle
Ausbildung
48 Prozent
also nicht unbedingt gerade ermutigend
fürs paar Kommentar noch viel besser
Frage
ja ja
sehr gut ja das Thema hat viel Männer
also der lost Vampir schrieb die vielen
heulenden und aggressiven Männer in den
Kommentaren zeigen das Problem wir haben
noch viel Arbeit vor uns welches sich
Männer so angreifen
ja das ist unvermietlich
wirkmächtig die Privileg ob man Marzi
ist unsichtbar und besteht drin das
mechanische Illusion leben das mehr als
mag gar nicht wirklich geschlachtet
sondern einfach Mensch ist einfacher
allgemeine Blick auf die waltet und
meine Damen wenn es kühl hat ja halt
einfach so mal bin ich bin das ist
natürlich das ist voll geil und da
gibt's überhaupt nichts diskutieren
wenn man EHRLICHKEIT neu verhandeln wenn
wir auf diese problematische Seite
vermeintlichkeit
auseinandersetzen jedes Mal muss ich
auseinandersetzen da bringen aber
natürlich ganz viele Männer auch in
betragen ist war das nicht dran das
andere nicht das ist noch dran ist das
ist Auseinandersetzung braucht mit
mannlichkeit aber so richtige stundlich
kann ich nicht finden dass das ganz
viele Männer trifft willst zumindest sie
aus tatsächlich
warme aber doch hat ignorante Position
und das ist doch gar nichts diskutieren
was mache ich mir einfach immer ja das
stimmt zum Beispiel
toxische Männlichkeit ist so tief
verankert in unserem Alltag es wäre toll
wenn du noch etwas auf die toxische
Männlichkeit als strukturelles Problem
eingehen könntest kannst du da drauf
antworten
Männlichkeit ist reserviert für das
gesamten Aufforderungen wo
gesellschaftlich formuliert werden und
für alle die wo was richtiger Mann
erkenne ich finde also da Normen
erforderlich Katalog wo muss
das heißt nicht dass mehr als Einzelner
nicht anders mit Haut andere aber das
ist einfach für sich selber entscheiden
kulturellen gesellschaftliche
Aufforderungen
[Musik]
nach wie vor und muss zielt sie die
toxische Männlichkeiten Normen als
solche zu überwinden und nicht mehr
jedem einzelnen martage du musst jetzt
ja wo die Kritik ist
Moment im Film wo ich gesagt das ist
zum Beispiel
allgemein
nicht unbedingt strukturelle ist aber
vielleicht muss ich diese Rentiere
Problem
es ist immer beides in der
Präventionsarbeit tut mir voll Verhalten
ist Prävention von Verhaltens Prävention
Rede und du sage ich ganz gut beides
Verhältnisprävention und
Rahmenbedingungen
und Verhaltens Prävention sind
Ufer Region jede einzelne was auch
machen und jetzt in unserem Fall ich bin
Suizid Prävention die Mama und das heißt
natürlich jeder einzelne Nummer Bucht
Unterstützung
ermunterricht
wir nur gut mit sich selber hilft
tatsächlich so und trotzdem Verhältnisse
Präventivmaßnahmen
die kulturelle die Leitbilder
vermeintlichkeit aber verhindern dass
überhaupt erst so viele Mann das Gefühl
lösen sie brauchen keine wirkliche
Zugang zu ihren Gefühl sie können da
sein Sami 12 das Leben ziehen
der Pink fährt noch geschrieben
Verband das Wort toxische Männlichkeit
toxic maskulinity nennt es von mir aus
suppression of emotions denn auch bei
mir ist das Wort im Gehirn mit man Bad
verlinkt und das obwohl ich weiß was es
bedeutet
Markus ist der Begriff toxische
mannlichkeit an und für sich schon
problematisch
Möglichkeit
und dir verwüstige oder dass das
verschwimmt zwischen mannlichkeit und
Masse über beides so giftig sind das ist
tatsächlich das Problem ja das verstehen
viele so wir da pink gravity heißt
aber bei Gedanken
mit sollen Aufgaben
immer häufiger gebraucht wird da ich
vielleicht noch ein bisschen sondern
mehr Luft Verletzlichkeit
[Musik]
gegenüber
schreibt
Militärdienst ist doch eine
Benachteiligung der Männer und das
Scheidungsrecht
das hat mir zwar schon viel Geld kostet
aber
nicht ich Militärdienst Benachteiligung
Mann
Sicht eindeutige diskriminiert aufgrund
von Kraft und das Minus sich nicht mit
mit der Schweizer Verfassung zu bringen
dass ich wichtig
im wander vor dass man zwar also mir
sind unterbeurteilungen Frauen
letztlich nicht beantworten
dass mein Vater das System wo die
Ungleichheit hervorbringt überwinde so
das hat wenn man nur Frauen
strukturelle diskriminiere aber ich
finde es auch okay dass man sagt ja also
ganz viele Privilegien aber auch
paar problematisch
Aspekt wo ich vor Ort werden zum
Beispiel
mega wichtig und ähm merci offen mit
Tieren deine Kommentare
es hat aber auch immer wieder Kommentare
von freudenkauer Reportage so zum
Beispiel vor Marijan See schrieb ich
finde es beeindruckend und berühmt mit
wie viel Ehrlichkeit und Selbstkritik
Salim an das Thema herangeht hey massive
Maul das freut mich
für dieses Thema
Beitrag leider wurde für meinen
Geschmack nur an der Oberfläche gekratzt
ich würde mich über mehrere Folgen zu
dem Thema freuen weil es viel komplexer
ist und mit vielen verschiedenen
Faktoren zusammenhängt hey voll über das
Thema
Fragen
doch unbedingt jetzt Kommentar